Michelle Obama made her signature
initiative when she was first lady
giving students less tasty lunches at
school you can't have pizza you can't
have all these delicious lunches we're
going to take away your milk and stuff
we're going to force you to have all
this supposedly healthy stuff school
children around America ground for eight
years see this is what I'm talking about
so Michelle Obama now has her own health
drink her health drink is called plasey
p-l-e-z-i according to a new report from
Bloomberg which is a left-wing Outlet
Michelle Obama's health drink would fail
the health standards set by the Obama
Administration Bloomberg discussed with
12 independent health professionals and
organizations they discovered that
place's current flavors would not meet
the requirements to be served at
elementary and middle schools if that is
not the story of liberalism I don't know
what is